[Music]
if i was going to look up one problem
cop was a prime example of what's gone
wrong here in baltimore where would i
start
because we want
we wanna run a little hypothetical about
you
i said we're on an investigation we're
following big time drug dealer like real
[ __ ] monster right
[Music]
yeah you know we get win on where he's
keeping his cash
and we actually come upon that cash
it's right there in front of us we just
you know we
take what would you think about that
[Applause]
everything changed when they came up
with that expression the war on drugs
with the war comes police militarization
the complete gutting of the fourth
amendment
they put me in a unit made up of a bunch
of the biggest crooks in the whole
goddamn department there's all this
money to be made and i'm somehow
supposed to be playing by the book with
these [ __ ]
so these cops caught lying
and when their abusive behavior remained
on the street they did
if it is the feds were honest the case
could go on for you what case
singapore escobar is the police
in a war you need warriors
you have enemies in a war civilians get
hurt and nobody does anything in a war
you count the bodies and then you call
them victories
are you angry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you